>>Aaron: So is this for you?
Will a flipped classroom work
in your subject area
and grade level?
We think the answer is
yes, and here's why.
So how do you flip
a science class?
Take your direct instruction,
put that on a video.
All that time you get
back, labs, labs, labs.
Get your kids involved
in hands on learning.
In fact, start going
down the road of inquiry.
Have your students
engage in a question
and an investigation before
you supplement then with some
of that video content.
>>Jon: In math class, it's
like the biggest no brainer
in the flip classroom.
Kids struggle with math content,
so put the problems and how
to do that on the video, so
that when they're in class,
they get the help
that they need.
But don't just solve problems,
make sure you're also bringing
in problems and projects
that enhance the learning
environment for your students.
>>Aaron: Can you flip
a class like English
that isn't real content heavy?
The answer's yes.
Think about the mechanics,
the mechanics of language,
the mechanics of grammar,
the mechanics of writing.
Those are the type
of instructional things
you could put on a video,
so that you can get your
time back in your class
to actually get the students
involved in the writing process.
You could also use those
videos as a remediation tool
for students who
come to your class
without the prerequisite skills.
>>Jon: What about a practical
subject like art or woodworking?
Well, make a video on techniques
and tools the students would use
so that in class, they can apply
those same techniques and tools.
So that in class, the
students are making things.
>>Aaron: Social studies
teachers can leverage video
to deliver concept overviews.
That way, you can get class time
back to get students involved
in dialog and reading
original documents.
That way, they're learning
more about why things happen
in history that just
what happened in history.
>>Jon: Can you flip a
physical education class?
Of course you can, so
make a video on how
to serve a volleyball, so
when the kids come to class,
they can serve volleyballs, or
how to play a particular game
so that when they come to
class, they can play the game.
This frees up class time
for teachers who are bogged
down with too much
explanation and rule giving.
>>Aaron: What about students who
learn at a pace that's different
than the pace that the
teacher is teaching?
They could be a student who
learns very, very quickly,
or a student who might
learn a little more slowly.
Well, having a flipped classroom in
place gives the students control
over the pace at which
they're exposed to content.
A student can watch a
video at double speed
and hear the content faster,
or a student can also pause...
or a student can also pause
and rewind if they need
to hear content or
slower or multiple times.
>>Jon: The common thread
in all of these examples is
that lower level skill
and concept stuff is done
on the video so that the
"in class" time is used
for higher order thinking,
deeper learning and
more engagement.